poom
nice shirt thanks I really appreciate
that say what's that peeking out from
under your jacket oh you mean this I
like this color better it's a good thing
they come in a variety of colors and
sizes whoa where'd you get that shirt oh
this one I made it I can make you one
too or you can go to sorta rocketjump
calm well this thing yeah so good thing
it's cyber mod because you can buy these
shirts on store Rock jump comm so he
celebrate Christmas or cyber Mon you can
buy the monster at rocketjump calm yep
and there's free shipping too so if you
ever wanted to show support for your
favorite YouTube channel and maybe show
off to your non-internet friends a
little bit instead of getting on pretty
WS missing hey guys hope you like the
shirts give any questions hit us up on
Twitter